[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
mark I know you're hurting but please
don't shut me out like this
she's coming back she's gonna come back
[Music]
[Applause]
ah Henry come on down here here my tool
room so we could be brothers
yeah well is it one with enough
mark you understand don't you
I'm leaving you now so I so I never have
to leave you again whoa not so fast how
about some breakfast sleep okay last
night
yeah good times good memories good
gracious what a day
vultures are taking in every an
artificial moment they give you cancer
who cares you're gonna die anyway let's
see if Joey's that smart would you want
look last Jimmy char hey pal can appeal
I took a real good look on my kid
brother Richard brought in the bathtub
your brother drowned just completely
blew shouldn't look at her eyes and lips
I just came to see what it felt
[Music]
you peel the cable back to here go ahead
Lock and Load don't hit her
just give her scared shy yeah but the
sights not right yet yeah oh you know I
spoke with Alice Davenport this morning
well she's a therapist who works with
Wallace right
because when you make a promise when
something's your fault
what did you do mark can sleep helping
your nephew deal with dead mother issues
and leash you're wearing a robe from
Sears making boys think their mothers
have come back from the dead every day
[Music]
do not worry Koken their love will be
their downfall
uh-uh-uh-uh-uh trainee at that side
negative targeting so much are you
scared
[Music]
keep the change ya filthy animal go
ahead tell him together
those marked dead choke me into it dan
merchants I'm gonna tell you what is it
what's wrong with Marc I don't know
she's been acting pretty weird I better
go see if he's okay I told my dad let's
see if you're okay are you okay mark
Kearney what did I tell you about coming
into my room you're working or anything
you didn't answer my question so I'm
gonna have to do it for one I'm not
coming to my room
my sweet little girl too bad something
were to happen to her she got hurt maybe
said weren't you Marc
okay accidents will happen
ah boys Henry what's going on I'm sorry
mom
we're playing this really Jumpgate we
weren't fighting
we're just playing won't remark yeah
all right but just not so rough okay I
mean you too what you were trying to
kill each other do you really have to go
out yeah we've been planning this for
weeks
you guys Connie
[Music]
good night little girl thank the Lord
you are well and that go to sleep said
miss Cavell sure the darling story mark
[Music]
I want to tuck in my kid sister
such a sweet little thing do you really
think I'd heard yes
[Music]
I don't think what happened at the pond
was an accident well what do you mean
kind of didn't just slip you don't know
what he is Henry tried to kill Connie
and you can do anything stop it stop it
that's a lie
stop it stop it that's a lie bark bark
bark
wait he scares me sometimes what does he
do
please don't mess with that I can't tell
you why not cuz Mark's my friend please
Henry tell me everything everything but
I guess you wouldn't understand but it's
true
she's my mother now
[Music]
hey mark don't suck with me don't suck
with me
[Music]
[Applause]
mark did you cry at your mom's funeral
yeah well what hurt her your mom my mom
what the hell's up Jimmy first for Mark
so violent
use your aggressive feelings boy let the
heat flow through you stayin here have
to tell you the truth now what happened
the night Richard died I was downstairs
playing don't lie to me
now you tell me did you kill Richard
what if I did Henry ladies and gentlemen
our beers today that's been on the run
for 90 minutes what I want out of each
and every one of you as a hard-target
search of every gas station residence
warehouse farmhouse henhouse outhouse a
dog
[Music]
doing some climbing feeling the weight
of the world on your shoulders your own
son tried to kill you as he's fighting
your nephew turning your perception of
reality completely upside down beverage
bar because your life's really fucked up
[Music]